the 2020 battle between President Trump
and Joe Biden it's heating up against
the backdrop of civil unrest in America
Trump is accusing Biden's campaign staff
of helping to get and here I'm quoting
anarchist out of jail the president's
comments are referring to reports that
Biden staffers made donations to a group
that helps Minneapolis protesters make
bail meanwhile Joe Biden he's slamming
the president today over his response to
the Cova 19 pandemic and its effect in
the black community the band-aid ripped
off by this pandemic in this president
nobody can pretend any longer what this
is all about
nobody can pretend who has been carrying
this on their back is Bonnard there's no
black there's been Hispanics Greg let me
start with you I think you know that
when the Biden people were giving
donations it was to bail out nonviolent
protesters I mean people in the
tradition of dr. King and yet you see
this Twitter thing make sound like he's
bailing out you know murderers what do
you think yeah I if you are posting bail
sight unseen then you aren't sure who
you're bailing out are you bailing out
the are you bailing out the fiends who
torched the bar built by that black
fireman for his retirement and he has no
insurance
are they bailing out that those people
are they bailing out the scum that beat
that woman unconscious with sticks while
she was protecting you may not know who
you're bailing out and it really is easy
for celebrities like Chrissy Teigen to
post bail from a gated community where
she knows she will never have to worry
about a threat in her life she I think
she actually was a spokesperson for
target and I guess she's making target
truly a target Dana how do you think Joe
Biden's doing you saw him there at the
church well it this week or this last
week was the first time that we've
actually seen him leave did I think that
buddy should be aware and I think that
we are we've talked about it a lot maybe
we haven't done enough but we ought we
know the statistics of the people than
the percentage of people who have died
or have been affected by coronavirus we
know them and and I believe that the
president has talked about this a
several times but perhaps we need to do
more in that area you know I I don't
like it when you have a crisis let alone
three crises all at once in the middle
of a presidential election year I think
we're about five or five months away on
Wednesday from election day so there is
going to be politics it's going to be
messy I think for the president to stay
mission focused as to dealing with these
and the facts on the ground and
restoring law and order and making sure
that the stimulus the fourth bill gets
done and gets to those people like the
one Greg which is talking about the one
who lost his bar but if he got a PPP
loan and he was gonna play that with his
employees and now he doesn't have
anywhere to go back to me
a lot of this is very complex and we
ought to appreciate that good point and
Jesse what do you think about you know I
was asking Dane about how buddy's doing
house Trump doing because you know today
with the governor saying you know get
tough take control and then the earlier
tweet about when the looting starts the
shooting starts and people saying that's
provocative what do you think about
these comments what I think is that he's
getting blamed for tweets when Democrats
are doing nothing while cities burned
I'm looking at action right now and
Trump's taken action he activated the
Department of Justice he condemned the
riots he's saying hey governor's we have
the National Guard on standby waiting
for the call to come in let's go I mean
what more do these governors and mayor's
need everyone's getting their butts
kicked all over the street they're
pulling people out of trucks Reginald
any style you know you have the women
store owners getting their clocks
cleaned in broad daylight by street
criminals and Trump's the target because
he tweeted something you got to be
kidding me
Joe Biden doesn't know what he's doing
here I mean what
you think they're gonna like oh I'm only
gonna make one Molotov cocktail and then
I'm gonna look at Trump's tweet now I'm
gonna make - it doesn't make any sense
judge Jeanine I was wondering what you
thought about the fact that Biden in
Delaware went to see some of the
protesters and stood with them did you
think that was a good gesture look look
it's a good thing you know there are
cops who were or were taking a knee now
who were hugging protesters there are
cops who were outraged by what happened
to George Floyd here but you know it's
nice for you know Joe Biden to complain
and he comes out for two things to put a
wreath on and - and to talk to some to
the family I believe as a family the
brother of George Floyd that's all good
but other than that ol Joe Biden is
doing is talking the president is saying
what Americans are thinking which is
dead out there
do something stop the violence stop the
Americans from having to suffer more
pain and more economic devastation he's
being a leader Joe Biden's probably
going back to his basement tonight Wow
okay judge